you mentioned uh pressure from
government
uh you've you've criticized Twitter
for uh the allowing giving in to
turkey's government censorship there's
also conspiracy theories or accusations
of Wikipedia
being
um open to pressure from government to
government organizations FBI and all
this kind of stuff uh is that right what
is the philosophy about pressure from
government and censorship so so we're
super hardcore on this we've never bowed
down to government pressure anywhere in
the world and we never will
um and we understand that we're hardcore
and actually there is a bit of nuance
about how different companies respond to
this but our response has always been
just to say no and if they threaten to
block
we'll knock yourself out you're going to
lose Wikipedia and that's been very
successful for us as a strategy
um because governments know they can't
just casually threaten to block
Wikipedia or block us for two days and
we're going to cave in immediately to
get back into the market and that's what
a lot of companies have done and I don't
think that's good
that we can go one level deeper and say
I'm actually quite sympathetic like if
you have staff members in a certain
country and they are at physical risk
you've got to put that into your
equation so I understand that like if if
Elon said actually I've got 100 staff
members on the ground in such and such a
country and if we don't comply
somebody's going to get arrested and it
could be quite serious
okay that's a tough one right that's
that's actually really hard
um but yeah no and then the FBI one no
no we like the criticism I saw I kind of
prepared for this because I saw people
responding to your request for questions
and I was like
somebody's like oh don't you think it
was really bad that you know I actually
restart to Stefan can you just make sure
I've got my facts right and the answer
is we
received zero requests of any kind from
the FBI or any of the other government
agencies for any changes to content in
Wikipedia and had we received those
requests at the level of the Wikimedia
Foundation we would have said
it's not our like we can't do anything
because Wikipedia is written by the
community and so the Wikimedia
Foundation can't change the content of
Wikipedia without causing I mean God
that would be a massive controversy you
can't even imagine
um what we did do and this is what I've
done I've I've been to China and met
with the minister of propaganda
we've had discussions with governments
all around the world
not because we want to do their bidding
but because we don't want to do their
bidding but we also don't want to be
blocked and we think actually having
these conversations are really important
now there's no threat of being blocked
in the U.S like that's just never going
to happen there is the first amendment
but in other countries around the world
it's like okay
what are you upset about let's have the
conversation like let's understand and
let's have a dialogue about it so that
you can understand where we come from
and what we're doing and why and then
you know some sometimes it's like
gee like if somebody complains that
something's bad in Wikipedia whoever
they are don't care who they are it
could be
you could be the government could be the
Pope I don't care who they are it's like
oh okay well our responsibility is
Wikipedia is to go oh hold on let's
check right is that right or wrong is
there something that we've got wrong in
Wikipedia not because you're threatening
to block us but because we want
Wikipedia to be correct so we do have
these dialogues with people and
um you know a big part of
like what was going on with
you might call it pressure on social
media companies or dialogue with
depending on you know as we talked
earlier grapple with the language
depending on what your view is
um in our case it was really just about
oh okay right they want to have a
dialogue about a covered information
misinformation we're this enormous
source of information which the world
depends on
we're going to have that conversation
right we're happy to say here's you know
if they say how do you know uh that
Wikipedia is not going to be pushing
some crazy anti-vaxx narrative
um first I mean I think it's somewhat
inappropriate for a government to be
asking pointed questions in a way that
implies
possible penalties I'm not sure that
ever happened because we would just go I
don't know the Chinese blocked us and
so so it goes right we're not going to
Cave into any kind of government
pressure but
um whatever the appropriateness of what
they were doing I think there is a role
for government in just saying let's
understand the information ecosystem
let's think about the problem of
misinformation disinformation in society
particularly around election security
um all these kinds of things so you know
I think it would be irresponsible of us
to get a call from a government agency
and say yeah why don't you just [__] off
you're the government uh but it would
also be irresponsible to go oh dear
government agent it's not happy let's
fix Wikipedia so the FBI loves us so
when you say you want to have
discussions with the Chinese government
or with organizations like CDC and who
it's to thoroughly understand what the
mainstream narrative is so that it can
be properly represented but not drive
what the articles are well I
it's actually important to say like
whatever the Wikimedia Foundation thinks
has no impact on what's in Wikipedia so
it's more about saying to them right we
understand you're the World Health
Organization or you're whoever and part
of your job is to sort of Public Health
is about Communications you want to
understand the world so it's more about
oh well let's explain how Wikipedia
works so it's more about explaining how
Wikipedia works and like hey it's the
volunteers yeah yeah it's a it's a
battle of ideas and here's how this the
sources are used yeah what are the
legitimate source is and what not a
legitimate sources yeah exactly I mean I
suppose there's some battle about what
is a legitimate Source there could be
statements made that CDC I mean like
there's uh government organizations
in general have sold themselves to be
the place where you go for expertise and
some of that has been uh it's a small
degree raised in question over the
response to the pandemic well I I think
in many cases and this goes back to my
topic of trust
so there were definitely cases of public
officials public organizations
where I felt like they lost the trust of
the public because they didn't trust the
public yeah and so the idea is like we
really need people to take this
seriously and take actions therefore
we're going to put out some overblown
claims because it's going to scare
people into behaving correctly you know
what that might work for a little while
but it doesn't work in the long run
because suddenly people go from a
default stance of like the Center for
Disease Control very well respected
scientific organization sort of I don't
know they've got uh fault in Atlanta
with the last vial of smallpox or
whatever it is that people think about
them and to go oh right these are
scientists we should actually take
seriously and listen to and they're not
politicized
um and they're you know it's like okay
and if you put out statements I don't
know if the CDC did but World Health
Organization whoever that are provably
false and also provably you kind of knew
they were false but you did it to scare
people because you wanted them to do the
right thing
it's like no you know what that's not
going to work in the long run like
you're going to lose people and now
you've got a bigger problem which is a
lack of trust in science a lack of trust
in authorities who are you know by and
large they're like quite boring
government bureaucrat scientists who
just are trying to help the world well I
I've been criticized
and I've been torn on this I've been
criticized for criticizing Anthony fauci
too hard uh the degree to which I
criticized him
is because he's a leader
and I'm just observing the effect in the
loss of trust in the institutions like
the NIH that where I personally know
there's a lot of incredible scientists
doing incredible work yeah and I have to
blame the leaders for the effects on the
distrust and the scientific work that
they're doing because
um of what I perceive as basic human
flaws of communication of arrogance of
ego of politics all those kinds of
things now you could say you're being
too harsh possible but I think that's
the whole point of free speech is you
can criticize the lead people who lead
leaders unfortunately or fortunately
responsible for the effects on society
to me Anthony fauci or whoever in the
scientific position or on the pandemic
had an opportunity to have a a FDR
moment or to get everybody together
Inspire about the power of science to
rapidly develop a vaccine that saves us
from this pandemic making future
pandemic that can threaten the
well-being of human civilization this
was epic and awesome and sexy and to me
when I talked to people about science
it's anything but sexy in terms of the
virology and biology development
um because it's been politicized it's
icky and people just don't want to like
I don't talk to me about the vaccine I
understand I got vaccinated just let's
switch topics
yeah well it's interesting because I as
I said I live in the UK and I think it's
all these things are a little less
politicized there and I I haven't played
close enough attention to
fauci to have a really strong view I'm
sure I would disagree with some things I
definitely you know
I remember hearing at the beginning of
the pandemic as I'm unwrapping my Amazon
package with this masks I bought because
I heard there's a pandemic and I just
was like I want some n95 mask please
uh and they were saying don't buy masks
and the motivation was because they
didn't want there to be shortages in
hospitals fine
but they were also statements of mass
school they're not effective and they
won't help you and then the complete
about phase two
you're you're ridiculous if you're not
wearing them you know it's just like no
like that that about face
just lost people from day one the
distress and the and the intelligence of
the public to deal with Nuance to deal
with it yeah this is exactly what you
know I think this is where the Wikipedia
neutral point of view
uh is and and should be an ideal and
obviously every article and everything
we could you you know me now and you
know how I am about these things but
like ideally is to say look we're happy
to show you all the perspectives this is
planned parenthood's View and this is
Catholic Church View and we're going to
explain that and we're going to try to
be thoughtful and and
put in the best arguments from all sides
because I trust you like you read that
and you're going to be more educated and
you're going to begin to make a decision
I mean I can just talk in the UK
the government
when we found out in the UK that
very high level government officials
were not following the rules they have
put on everyone else yeah I moved from I
had just become a UK citizen just a
little while before the pandemic and you
know it's kind of emotional like you get
a passport in a new country and you feel
quite good and I did my oath to the
queen and they drag the poor old lady
out to tell us all to be good and I was
like We're British and we're going to do
the right things and and you know it's
going to be tough but we're going to you
know so you have that kind of Dunkirk
Spirit moment
and you're like following the rules to a
T and then suddenly it's like well
they're not following the rules and so
suddenly I shifted personally from
I'm gonna follow the rules even if I
don't completely agree with them but
I'll still follow because I think we've
got all chip in together to like you
know what I'm gonna make wise and
thoughtful decisions for myself and my
family
and that generally is going to mean
following the rules but it's basically
you know when they're you know at
certain moments in time like you're not
allowed to be in an outside space unless
you're exercising
I'm like
I think I can sit in the park and read a
book yeah like it's gonna be fine like
that's irrational rule which I would
have been following just personally of
like I'm just going to do the right
thing yeah and the loss of trust I think
at scale was probably harmful to science
and to me the scientific method and the
scientific Community is is uh one of the
biggest hopes at least to me for the
survival and the thriving of human
civilization absolutely and I you know I
think you see some of the ramifications
of this there's always been like pretty
anti-science anti-vax people okay that's
always been a thing but I feel like it's
bigger now uh simply because of that
lowering of trust so a lot of people
yeah maybe it's like you say a lot of
people are like yeah I got vaccinated
and I really don't want to talk about
this because it's so toxic you know and
that's unfortunate because I think
people should say what what an amazing
thing and you know
there's also a whole range of discourse
around
If This Were a disease that were
primarily that was primarily killing
babies
I think people's emotions about it would
have been very different right or wrong
than the fact that when you really
looked at the
the sort of death rate of getting
covered well it's really dramatically
different if you're if you're late in
life
um this was a really dangerous and if
you're 23 years old yeah well it's not
great like and Long Cove is a thing and
all of that but and I think some of the
public Communications again were failing
to properly
contextualize not all of it you know but
it's a complicated matter but yeah